really helps our offense with our face
thank you coach thank you thanks to
Diamond hand Lonnie Walker gets up the
first shot of the fourth and number four
drills a three for L.A
for a big time minutes in game two and
darwinham went back to him for 20.
Draymond Green and a hot pass right
through Wiggins Ronnie walker Beats
Thompson Lonnie Walker lays it in
[Applause]
Draymond Green
turns it over Lonnie Walker great effort
Moody comes and knocks that out of
bounds two great efforts by The Warriors
oh Ronnie Walker delivers another in the
fourth quarter
Terry gotta hand on that Walker down
five to shoot Walker's feeling it Walker
long two okay
Walker and Lonnie Walker has been huge
here in the fourth nine points all in
this quarter Laker ball here two-point
game Lakers Trail Lonnie Walker's been
excellent in this fourth quarter he
stays and Lonnie Walker keeps it rolling
he's got 11 all 11 coming in the fourth
to your point coach Gotta Stay Ready
Lonnie Walker guarded by Curry Walker
pull up Walker hits another one it's the
Lottie Walker game
Anthony
LeBron who the go-to guy for the Lakers
is Lonnie Walker the fourth 13 in the
corner
86 on the season ghost get along
but it's Stephen Curry he's made a lot
of those in his career Lonnie Walker 15
fourth
James finds Reeves ball
in the hands of the Laker and that's it
ball game over the Lakers come storming
back in game four
and now up 3-1 in this best of seven
the best fourth quarter team in the NBA
the Lakers outscoring the Warriors
27-17 in the four tonight
95 success rate when teams go up 3-1
and the praise for Lonnie Walker raining
down on him rightly so what a
performance
that's a motivational speech for a
lifetime for Lonnie Walker well and it's
a motivational speech to all those guys
who are right in the bench at any level
be ready when your opportunity comes
your play can gain the confidence of
your coach 15 points all in the fourth
quarter
let's send it over to Chris Haynes I'm
here with LeBron James I'm tying his
shoes right now